and here's a beautiful video I saw this
over the weekend this is a young lady
named Savannah Hernandez she works for
Turning Point USA and one of the things
that she does
she goes to college campuses and she
talks to college kids about what they
think now obviously as a turning point
uh representative she is a conservative
or at least certainly conservative
leaning I think she's pretty libertarian
we're going to get her on a Friday panel
I already talked to her about it but she
went to a couple college campuses to ask
white students about their white
privilege and watch this beautiful
moment of her deprogramming this care
right in front of his eyes
I I grew up as a white man and you
you're the exact opposite you know and
so it's like my experiences are going to
be different from yours how come I think
uh you know there's a thing of like
white privilege uh what privileges do
you have that I don't have oh see that's
the question I keep asking myself
because like in this day and age like
all the laws I say all the laws you know
I'm
it's hard to speak on something I'm not
fully knowledgeable of so like I'm sorry
if I like make a mistake in saying this
but it's like
like uh
hmm don't you think it's a problem in
society when white people think that
they have more privileges than brown or
black people
yeah and I think that's sort of the
agenda that's pushed off because
personally it's like not that I think
I'm more privileged than anyone else
because I had to work to get where I was
and that's like why do you have that
mentality immediately where you you know
kind of apologize to me like let's talk
about privilege let's talk about I'm a
white man in America so we could have
grown up differently why is that your
first initial reaction to me as a brown
woman
you're getting me good see there's a
kind of conversations that I love having
um and I think it comes from a place of
like
uh I wouldn't say caution but like in
this day and age people are so quick to
judge and react and cancel and so I
guess it's that that like caution to go
into an interview like this on like I
don't know where we're at but now I know
where we're at and I can like uh go for
real guys that's beautiful and that is a
white pill and that is Hope and did you
get at the end there when she really
turned it on him he didn't know why he
said it he didn't know why he said it
it's the cudgel of cancellation that
they have held over everybody's head you
will put empathy and really faux
unknowing empathy for other people above
everything including yourself you don't
know why but you know why you'll do it
because otherwise they will destroy you
well that's one less dude that they're
going to destroy because he just got it
so they may come after him I don't know
what school he's at I have no doubt that
the activists will come after him and
blah blah blah but as he said he had to
work it wasn't so easy for him and even
if it was easy for him even if his
parents were multi-millionaires should
he be punished because of that
we all know the answer
[Music]